.
Ich wurde gemobbt,
ausgeschlossen und ausgenutzt.
So ziemlich alles, was schlecht ist.
Ich wollte nicht mehr
die Person sein, die ich war,
oder gar nicht mehr sein.
Es war einfach Horror, wirklich.
Wie viel Sport kann ich machen, wie
wenig essen, bis ich zusammenklappe?
Am tiefsten Punkt stand ich
dreimal täglich auf die Waage.
Es war echt schlimm.
Meine Angst ist, dass ich nicht
gut genug bin für meine Kollegen,
nicht gut genug für die Schule ...
(Mann) Wer kennt die Bedeutung
des Wortes Depression?
Starke Gefühle von Traurigkeit,
Freudlosigkeit, keine Energie mehr.
Abwehr gegen aussen, Aggressivität,
Wut, "lass mich in Ruhe".
Plötzlich diese Gefühle von Unglück,
die aus mir gekommen sind.
Ich wusste nicht, wie umgehen damit.
Ich habe es nicht verstanden.
# Vielleicht
könnt' ich ein Held sein,
# der in die Welt hinauszieht
und ganz passabel aussieht.
# Mit Schild im festen Griff.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
* Sanfte Musik *
Ich war einfach froh,
dass ich einen Ort gefunden hatte,
wo ich mich zurückziehen konnte,
wo ich einfach sein konnte.
Im Moment ging es nur darum, dass es
einigermassen aushaltbar wird.
Hallo.
- (Mann) Hallo, Gioia.
* Bellen *
Ich bin in der Küche, komm rauf.
Das hat mir mega Sicherheit gegeben.
Zu wissen:
Ich kann machen, was mir guttut.
Schön, bist du da. Cool.
- Danke.
Zu verstehen, was mit mir passiert.
Dinge zu finden, die mir helfen.
Danke.
- Bitte schön.
Der Weg war für mich am schlimmsten.
Es war nicht sicher, ich habe mich
überhaupt nicht sicher gefühlt.
Im Kopf hatte ich immer das Bild,
wie ich vor den Zug springe.
Ähm ...
Und ich hatte Angst,
dass das passieren würde.
Man ist wie paralysiert im Moment.
Du kannst dich nicht ablenken.
Alles im Körper zieht sich zusammen.
Es ist wirklich nicht cool.
Ich habe einfach funktioniert
im Gymi.
Ich bin aber jeweils
wie ein Elend nach Hause gekommen.
Und dann hat Mama irgendwann gesagt,
sie nehme mich aus der Schule.
Sie wusste auch:
Es ist nicht mehr gut.
Die sozialpädagogische Einrichtung
Heimetli wird zum Anker für Gioia.
... hier sein zu dürfen.
Aufgrund des Erlebten bringen sie
Verhaltensmuster oder Ängste mit,
Verletzungen
aufgrund ihrer Geschichte.
Wir helfen ihnen, damit umzugehen,
damit sie Resilienz aufzubauen.
Während eines halben Jahres
kann Gioia hier zur Ruhe kommen
und gesund werden.
Wie sie
verlieren immer mehr Jugendliche
in der Schweiz
den Glauben an die Zukunft.
2022 geben erstmals weniger als 50 %
aller Jugendlichen an,
optimistisch
in die Zukunft zu blicken.
Die Stadt Zürich hat deshalb
ein Pilotprojekt gestartet.
Willkommen zu dieser Lektion.
Es geht darum, Sorge zu tragen.
D.h., trag dir Sorge,
schau gut zu dir.
Nicht nur körperlich,
gesundheitlich,
sondern auch vom Gemüt,
von der Verfassung, vom Gefühl her.
Das schauen wir heute zusammen an.
Wer mag Döner?
Wenn es jemand nicht mag,
bitte sitzen bleiben.
Das darf man auch.
Ah, jetzt stehen alle auf, gut.
Bitte wieder setzen.
Wir machen jetzt ein paar Fragen.
Nächste Frage:
Wer ist heute
grundsätzlich zufrieden?
Wenn nicht, bitte sitzenbleiben.
Ihr sollt eure eigenen Gefühle
entwickeln und dazu stehen.
Super, danke.
Wer kennt die Bedeutung
des Wortes Depression?
Wer hat dieses Wort
schon mal gehört?
Ein paar, ja.
Darf ich dich fragen,
was heisst das?
Wenn man während einer langen Zeit
sehr unglücklich ist
und nicht mehr glücklich denken kann
und im Leben keinen Sinn mehr sieht.
Ja, genau.
Das sind alles Leute
aus verschiedenen Lebensbereichen
und Kulturen, die sagen,
sie hätten in ihrem Leben
solche Zeiten durchgemacht.
Alles Leute, die erfolgreich sind,
vermögend, reich sind.
Es kann jeden treffen,
man sucht sich das nicht aus.
Die Häufigkeit ist jedes
fünfte Mädchen, das berichtet:
"Ja, mir ist es über Wochen
und Monate so schlecht gegangen",
dass es in Richtung einer
depressiven Episode, Phase geht
und jeder zehnte Junge.
Was ist passiert?
- Keine Ahnung.
In letzter Zeit
geht es mir nicht so gut.
Ich schreibe schlechte Noten.
Gehen wir zur Schulsozialarbeiterin?
Du musst nicht allein gehen.
Ich komme mit.- Okay, zusammen.
Alleine gehe ich nicht.
Es ist wichtig. Ich möchte nicht,
dass es dir schlecht geht.- Okay.
Die Pandemie belastet viele Menschen.
Unter 18-Jährige leiden am meisten.
64 % geben eine sehr hohe
oder hohe psychische Belastung an.
Bei den 18- bis 39-Jährigen
sind es 48 %,
bei den 40- bis 64-Jährigen
leiden noch 39 %,
bei den über 65-Jährigen
nur noch 27 %
unter sehr hoher
oder hoher psychischer Belastung.
Bei den Jungen hat sich der Anteil
der psychisch Belasteten
im ersten Lockdown verdoppelt,
im zweiten sogar verdreifacht.
Dabei verstärkt die Pandemie auch
soziale und gesundheitliche
Ungleichheiten.
Auch Emil ist betroffen.
In der Pandemie gleitet er
in eine schwere Essstörung,
in eine Krise,
die er längst hinter sich glaubte.
Emil und Leonie haben sich vor Jahren
in der Klinik für Jugendpsychiatrie
kennengelernt.
Seither haben sie
eine tiefe Freundschaft aufgebaut.
"Agenda mitnehmen." Megawichtig!
Megapoetisch.
Leonie kennt die Essproblematik
aus eigener Erfahrung.
Lange hat sie diese
für sich behalten.
... bis ich nicht mehr
in der Lage war,
normal in die Schule zu gehen,
den Alltag zu bewältigen,
weil ich körperlich zu schwach war.
Ich hatte auch keinen Anhaltspunkt,
was ich machen soll im Leben,
ich hatte keine Freude mehr.
Es hat sich
mit einer Art Depression vermischt.
Die Essstörung wurde
zu meinem einzigen Lebensinhalt,
zu meiner Orientierung,
daran habe ich mich festgehalten.
Deshalb wollte ich das
auch nicht ändern.
Dank ihrer eigenen Erfahrungen
konnte sie vor einem Jahr
Emil aus der Krise helfen.
Ich habe versucht,
Emil gegenüber zu argumentieren,
dass es nur diese zwei Szenarien
gebe, die offensichtlich sind:
Entweder du holst dir Hilfe
oder irgendwann
wird dir die Hilfe aufgezwungen,
weil dein Leben und deine Existenz
bedroht sind.
Und du hängst an deiner Ausbildung,
willst sie unbedingt fertig machen.
Wenn du wartest,
bis es dir noch schlechter geht,
dann könntest du
gar nicht weitermachen.
Das war es,
was bei dir angeschlagen hat.
Ja, ich wollte wirklich
meine Lehre fertig machen.
Weil ich solche Freude
an dieser Ausbildung habe
und so interessiert bin.
Du fandest, du könnest dir
auf keinen Fall leisten,
eine Pause einzulegen
und ein paar Monate oder Wochen
weg zu sein in einer Behandlung.
Ich fand: "Wenn du so weitermachst,
kommt es so weit."
Es war echt schlimm.
Ich habe grosse Probleme
mit meinem Selbstwert.
Ich habe oft das Gefühl,
man mag mich nicht.
Wenn du jugendlich bist, bist du
ohnehin unsicher in dir selbst.
Und wenn du das Handy nimmst,
siehst du erst mal 30 Leute
mit megavielen Filtern
und Bearbeitungen,
die selbst essgestört sind.
Du denkst, die hätten schöne Körper
und kriegen auch viele Kommentare,
wie schön sie aussähen.
Du bist megabeeinflussbar
in diesem Alter.
Dann googelst du,
wie du abnehmen könntest.
Und du bist jugendlich
und ungeduldig.
Du schaust,
wie du in zwei Wochen abnimmst.
Und dann bist du
in Essstörungsforen.
Und dann bist du so weit.
* Sanfte, schwebende Klänge *
Emil
hat eine lange Leidensgeschichte.
Seine Pubertät ist schmerzvoll.
Ich war immer bunter, lauter,
ein bisschen zu viel.
Der kleine Junge,
der viele Fragen stellt
und Erwachsene
in den Wahnsinn treiben konnte.
Mein Leben
wäre schon einfacher gewesen,
wenn ich "normal" gewesen wäre,
in der Norm.
Ich war immer ein wenig
der Spezielle.
Ich habe mich sehr oft
unzulänglich gefühlt.
Dass ich zu wenig bin
oder zu wenig gut für die Schule.
Zu dumm.
Ich habe es für mich behalten,
dass es mir nicht gut geht.
Es gab Mobbingkreise, in denen ich
rumgeschubst worden bin.
Ich musste einmal im Spital
eine Platzwunde am Kopf kleben.
Alle waren dabei.
Das hat die Leute vereint:
Emil fertigmachen.
Ich ging immer weniger
in die Schule.
Zu dieser Zeit begann ich,
mich selbst zu verletzen.
Ich bin voll ins Loch gefallen.
* Monotone Klänge *
Mehrere Klinikaufenthalte folgen.
Zu seinem Schutz muss Emil
im Isolierzimmer übernachten.
Ich wurde von meinen
eigenen Gefühlen überrollt.
Die ganzen aufgestauten Emotionen
haben mich umgeworfen.
Heute kann Emil
sein Leben selbst in die Hand nehmen.
Und Zukunftspläne schmieden.
Boah, das ist ein cooles Sofa.
- Sitzen wir mal Probe.
Es hat ein bisschen viel Glitzer.
- Das wird es ohnehin haben.
Das stimmt.
Gibt es kein Preisschild?
- Es hat keins.
Ah doch, hier gibt es eines.
- Ah ja?
Alter! 319 Stutz.
Nein! Da kaufe ich ein neues!
- Ja, das kann man tatsächlich.
Wir müssen eben hier wohnen.
Nein.
Dann eben nicht.
Wozu seid ihr hier?
Ohne konkretes Ziel.
Für die Wohnung vielleicht,
aber nicht dieses Sofa.
Was für eine Wohnung?
Wir haben eine Wohnung bekommen.
Im Januar können wir zusammenziehen.
Jetzt schauen wir hier Möbel an,
wir benötigen einiges.
Wir haben realisiert,
was wir alles brauchen.
Schau mal, diese Jacke!
Wie findest du sie?
Ist wie ein abgehackter Trenchcoat.
Wieso nicht?- Ja, voll.
Wie wichtig ist euch euer Äusseres?
- Wenn es Ärmel hat ...
Nein, leider etwas wichtiger,
als es sein sollte. Zu wichtig.
Das heisst?
Ich fühle mich oft unzufrieden
mit meinem Aussehen
und vergleiche mich selbst
mit anderen.
Im Verlauf einer Woche
sehe ich praktisch immer gleich aus.
Manchmal denke ich, ich sei
megaschön und fühle mich attraktiv.
Und am Folgetag -
ich sehe genau gleich aus -
finde ich, ich sehe seltsam aus
und habe absurde Körperproportionen
und finde mich
überhaupt nicht schön.
Obwohl sich rein physikalisch
nichts verändert hat.
Es ist mein Körperbild,
das gestört ist.
Weisst du, was der Auslöser ist?
Nein, nicht wirklich.
Ich habe in der Therapie
schon oft darüber geredet.
Ich habe ein Problem
mit Perfektionismus.
Auf schulischer Ebene
oder was meinen Körper anbelangt.
Es sieht so starr aus, so streng.
Also dann so?
- Nein, grauenhaft. Ja, egal.
Wie muss dein Körper sein,
damit er dir gefällt?
Es geht nicht um meinen Körper.
Denn ich bin körperlich
schon an viele Grenzen gegangen.
Es war nie okay für mich.
Es geht eher darum,
dass ich meinen Körper respektiere,
akzeptiere, wie er ist,
wie er funktioniert, was er macht.
Ich glaube nicht, dass ...
... die Lösung des Problems
das Verändern meines Körpers ist.
Ich habe das ausprobiert
und es ist nicht gut gelaufen.
Es ist eher so, dass ich mich selbst
mal als schön ansehen können müsste.
Das ist eine Sache
von Selbstakzeptanz,
eine psychische,
keine körperliche Sache.
Gut, dass du das verstanden hast.
Ich musste dir megaoft sagen, dass
dein Körper nicht das Problem ist.
Ich muss einfach damit leben.
- Du musst es nun mal glauben.
Gut, wir haben es.
- Wir haben alles.
Hamburg ist meine neue Heimat.
Ich bin seit vier Jahren hier.
Ich will nicht mehr weg.
Ich bleibe noch länger
als für die Ausbildung da.
Ich musste mich einleben
in die Grossstadt.
Aber seit ich da bin,
ist es einfach wunderschön.
Beneon bildet sich in Hamburg
in Tanz, Gesang und Schauspiel aus.
Es war ein mutiger Schritt,
aber der richtige.
Ich hätte damals nicht gedacht,
dass es so anstrengend wird
und so anspruchsvoll,
aber ich bin stolz und froh,
dass ich es gemacht habe.
Es war auf jeden Fall
die richtige Entscheidung.
# Vielleicht ... Hm ...
# Vielleicht
könnt' ich ein Held sein,
# der in die Welt hinauszieht
und ganz passabel aussieht.
Ich finde es einfach, meine Gefühle
oberflächlich auszudrücken.
Aber es ist megaschwierig,
einen Zugang tief in mir zu finden.
* Singübungen *
Ich habe mal ein Lied gesungen
im ersten Jahr.
Da haben wir gelernt, eigene
Emotionen mit ins Lied zu nehmen.
Das habe ich gemacht und all meine
Probleme auf ein Lied projiziert.
Ich bin zusammengebrochen,
in Tränen ausgebrochen.
Die Lehrerin sagte, an diesem Stück
könnten wir nicht mehr arbeiten,
wir müssten es beiseitelegen,
ich soll etwas Neues machen.
Es wurde einfach zu deep,
aber meine Gefühle
der tiefen Depression und die Ängste
von damals sind hochgekommen.
* Monotone Klänge *
Meine Familie und meine Kollegen
haben nichts geahnt,
weil ich immer so gewirkt habe, als
hätte ich mein Leben voll im Griff.
Plötzlich diese Gefühle von Unglück,
die aus mir gekommen sind.
Ich wusste nicht, wie umgehen damit.
Und einfach so Panikattacken,
die von innen rauskamen.
Ich habe einfach nichts verstanden
und fühlte mich so unwohl.
So ein Tief wie damals
habe ich noch nie erlebt.
Ich habe gemerkt,
dass mir die Mutter gefehlt hat,
dass mir die Nähe zum Vater
gefehlt hat,
weil er so viel arbeiten musste,
und in der Schule
hatte ich Probleme.
Dann ist die Pubertät dazugekommen.
Ich habe mich äusserlich
einfach nicht schön gefühlt,
innerlich nicht schön gefühlt
und ungeliebt von allen.
V.a. auch von mir selbst.
Das war der Hauptgrund, weshalb ich
in ein solches Loch gefallen bin.
In seiner Verzweiflung
gerät Beneon in eine Essstörung.
Mehrere Zusammenbrüche folgen.
Schliesslich begibt er sich
in ambulante Therapie.
Seine drei Geschwister
sind bereits ausgezogen,
als Benenon
seine Maturaarbeit schreibt:
ein selbst komponiertes Lied,
dem alleinerziehenden Vater gewidmet.
Bei der Aufführung
meiner Maturaarbeit
hat er mir gesagt,
dass er stolz sei,
dass ich ein Talent habe.
Nach vielen Jahren,
in denen er gesagt hat,
dass ich nicht singen könne,
hat er endlich gesagt,
dass ich damit
etwas auf die Reihe bringen könne.
Zwei Wochen danach ist er gestorben.
Deshalb bedeutet mir das Lied
auch so viel mehr als nur ein Lied.
# ... that I can be alone,
I can be alone.
# I don't need you
to tell me I'm wrong.
# I can be alone,
I can be alone.
# I don't need you
to tell me I'm wrong.
# I can be alone,
please leave me alone.
# Fuck off, get out of my head.
Wenn ich mal
spätabends nach Hause komme,
ist es dunkel und leer
und dann fühle ich mich auch leer.
Dann kann es auch vorkommen,
dass ich einfach weinen muss
oder einfach meinen Vater vermisse.
Oder einfach in diesem Moment
lieber nicht allein wäre.
Doch dann kann ich
meinem Bruder schreiben,
meiner Schwester schreiben und dann
klärt sich eigentlich alles wieder.
Das einzig Schwierige
am Alleinwohnen ist,
am Morgen vor der Schule
aufzustehen.
Wenn man aufsteht, ist es super,
aber aus dem Bett zu kommen,
ohne dass einen der Vater anschreit,
ist schon schwierig.
Trotzdem und dank der Therapie
schafft Beneon die Matura
und den Sprung nach Hamburg.
# Vielleicht
könnt' ich ein Held sein,
# der in die Welt hinauszieht
und ganz passabel aussieht.
# Mit Schild im festen Griff.
# Ein Wikinger womöglich,
ein Kerl mit rauer Seele,
# der riecht wie 'ne Makrele
auf seinem Drachenschiff.
# Ich setzte Kurs ...- Danke.
"Ich stehe über den Dingen."
Das sind ja die Träume,
die du hast.
"Das wäre so toll."
Das gibt dir die Kraft:
"Wäre das toll, wenn ich das wäre."
Plötzlich kommst du wieder in
die Realität und denkst: "Scheisse."
"Das bin ich nicht.
Ich bin nur ein Oger." Ja?
Danke, damit kann ich was anfangen.
Ich finde es gut,
kritisiert zu werden.
Wenn man aber auch gelobt wird
von anderen Dozenten,
ist es schwierig herauszufinden,
wo ich wirklich gut bin.
Denn jeder hat eine andere Meinung.
# Daddy was the new sensation,
got himself a congregation ...
Ah, ja, genau!
Wer auf die Bühne möchte,
ist ganz besonders mit Kritik
und Leistungsdruck konfrontiert.
Damit umzugehen, hat Beneon gelernt.
Ich habe in der Therapie
vieles gelernt,
das ich nun im Leben umsetze.
V.a. zu merken, wenn etwas passiert.
Z.B., wenn ich an einem Morgen
nicht aufstehen kann,
weil es mir nicht gut geht,
dann weiss ich, dass ich das
nicht noch einmal tun sollte.
Weil ich die Folgen kenne,
wenn ich mich
in dieser depressiven Phase
sinken lasse oder dagegen ankämpfe.
Es ist einfacher, das sofort
zu killen, als zu versinken.
* Dramatische Musik *
Um den Umgang mit Kritik zu üben,
bietet die Schule
das Fach Mental Care an.
Ich musste einen negativen
Glaubenssatz sagen.
Ich sagte:
"Ich bin nicht gut genug."
Sie sagte: "Doch!"
Alle anderen hätten gesagt:
"Du bist toll, mega."
Und sie sagte einfach: "Doch."
Da wusste ich:
Dieser Satz bleibt mir im Kopf.
Immer wenn es mir schlecht geht,
denke ich: doch.
Dann geht es mir besser.
Das hilft wirklich.
* Anschwellende, monotone Klänge *
Leistungsdruck, soziale Medien,
Covid, Klimakrise, Krieg -
das ist viel Druck
auf ein junges Gemüt.
Auch bei Gioia bricht die Krise
während der Pandemie aus.
Ihre Eltern und die jüngere Schwester
versuchen ihr beizustehen.
Trotzdem gleitet Gioia
in eine tiefe Depression.
Die Pandemie erzwingt den Rückzug:
Schulunterricht im Zimmer,
keine Abgrenzung
zwischen Schule und Freizeit
und wenig Aussicht
auf unbeschwerte Ablenkung.
Man war isoliert zu Hause, allein,
man konnte seine Kolleginnen
und Kollegen nicht mehr treffen.
Man war mehr
auf den soziale Plattformen.
Diese Ansammlung an Negativität,
diese Reizüberflutung ...
Da sind soundso viele Menschen
ermordet worden,
dort ist ein Krieg ausgebrochen.
Jedes Mal,
wenn ich daran gedacht habe,
bekam ich extrem Angst,
weil ich dachte,
ich würde die Zukunft
gar nicht mehr erleben.
Durch das viele Zuhausehocken
hast du auch viel mehr nachgedacht.
Was ist damals passiert?
Weshalb wurde ich früher gemobbt?
In der vierten bis sechsten
Primarschule gab es eine Anführerin.
Ich kam immer
total gebrochen nach Hause.
Meine Eltern rieten mir,
Nein zu sagen, wegzugehen von ihnen.
Aber ich habe mich nicht getraut.
Ich war so klein.
Ich hatte niemals die Stärke.
Und gerade,
weil sie mich so runtergemacht hat,
hat sie genau den Kern getroffen.
Sie hat es geschafft, mich zu
beeinflussen und zu drangsalieren.
Irgendwie
habe ich es trotzdem geschafft,
dort durchzukommen.
Es geht dir heute noch sehr nahe.
- Mhm.
Es tut mir so leid
für mein kleines Ich.
Sie war so unschuldig.
Ja, das ist megaschlimm.
Bei jungen Menschen
steigen die Hospitalisierungen
wegen psychischer Störungen in den
vergangenen Jahren immer weiter an.
Die Pandemie verschärft diesen Trend.
Zum ersten Mal
übertreffen die Hospitalisierungen
aufgrund psychischer Störungen
diejenigen von Verletzungen.
Besonders häufig betroffen
sind junge Frauen.
In den Pandemiejahren steigt die Zahl
der stationären Spitalaufenthalte
wegen psychischer Störungen
bei den Mädchen um 6 %,
im Folgejahr um beispiellose 26 %.
Bei den Jungen beträgt der Anstieg
lediglich 2 % und dann 6 %.
Es herrscht ein Notstand
an Therapieplätzen und Fachleuten.
Ein neues Zentrum in Zürich
bietet Soforthilfe für Jugendliche.
Kaum eröffnet, ist der Betrieb
bereits voll ausgelastet.
(Frau) Guten Morgen.
Am Wochenende hat K. angerufen,
unsere ambulante Patientin.
Sie hatte grossen Streit
mit ihrer Mutter.
Sie wollte wieder stationär kommen,
dann hat man nichts mehr gehört.
E. hatte kein gutes Wochenende,
wollte aber nicht darüber sprechen.
L. hat gestern Abend eine SMS
von einer Kollegin erhalten,
die sich suizidal geäussert hat.
Nachher
hat sie nichts mehr von ihr gehört.
Das war im Spätdienst Thema.
G. hatte Streit
mit ihrem Pflegevater.
Das war wohl nicht so gut.
Dann hat die Mutter noch angerufen.
Sie hat erzählt,
dass das WC verschmutzt gewesen sei.
Anscheinend
hat sie zu Hause erbrochen.
Hier hat sie
übermässig viel gegessen.
Sie war auf der Station
am Abend ziemlich aufgedreht.
Im Kinderbereich hat man mehr Jungs.
Der Junge
wird viel früher auffällig,
beginnt Streit auf dem Pausenplatz
oder schon im Kindergarten.
Das Mädchen
macht es mehr mit sich aus
und dann kommt die Pubertät
und irgendwann bricht es aus.
In der neuen Station
erhalten die Jugendlichen
eine intensive
und individuelle Therapie.
Guten Morgen miteinander.
Aufstehen! Es ist 7.30 Uhr.
Guten Morgen.
Es ist wieder mal Montag.
Ich hoffe,
ihr hattet gutes Wochenende.
Mir geht es nicht so gut.
Ich bin müde
und sonst ist es nicht so gut.
Ich bin auch müde, sonst voll okay.
Nicht so gut.
- Mittel.
Äh ... Nicht besonders gut.
Nicht besonders gut.
Aber auch nicht besonders schlecht?
Das Angebot hat es sicher gebraucht.
Schön, dass es dies gibt.
Es ist eine Entlastung, aber
in der ganzen Psychiatrielandschaft
müsste es noch mehr davon geben,
damit man die Jugendlichen so
schnell wie möglich aufnehmen kann.
Der Notstand ist immer noch da?
Der Notstand
ist garantiert immer noch da.
Die Jugendlichen leben im Life
einen beinahe normalen Alltag
mit Schule und Freizeit.
Ihre Bezugspersonen sind
in die Behandlung eng eingebunden.
Ich fände es gut, wenn wir
die nächsten Tage nutzen könnten.
Wenn du abwechslungsweise zu Hause
und hier übernachten würdest.
Damit wir das üben können.
Wäre das in deinem Sinne?
Mhm.
Im geschützten Rahmen
können die Jugendlichen
neue Perspektiven aufbauen.
Man hat hier immer den Support
von Betreuern.
Man weiss:
Wenn es einem schlecht geht,
ist immer jemand da, der zuhört.
Es gibt die Sicherheit:
Wenn man stationär ist,
ist man auch den ganzen Tag
recht gut beschäftigt.
Das hilft, etwas Struktur
in den Alltag reinzubringen.
Es ist etwas,
um das Feuer zu löschen
und dann in der Therapie
wieder aufzubauen.
Ich glaube, für den kurzen
Aufenthalt bringt es sehr viel.
Sie kommen wegen Depressionen,
Angststörungen oder Suizidgedanken.
In ihrer Krise
sollen sie früh aufgefangen werden,
damit sie rasch
in ihr Umfeld zurückkehren können.
Das Zusammensein
mit anderen Betroffenen hilft,
die eigene Situation zu akzeptieren.
Es ist noch ein grosses Tabuthema.
Es gibt noch viele Vorurteile
gegenüber
psychischen Instabilitäten.
Ich finde das nicht richtig.
Man kann erstens nichts dafür.
Zweitens ist es ein wichtiges Thema,
weil viele Menschen Suizid begehen,
sich etwas antun.
Auch was Jugendliche
Gleichaltrigen antun,
kann psychische Krankheiten auslösen.
Alle Formen von Mobbing haben
in den vergangenen Jahren zugenommen.
Ausschliessen, auslachen, drohen,
sexuelle Belästigung,
schlagen oder Dinge zerstören -
Die Druckmittel
sind vielfältig und perfid,
das daraus entstandene Leid gross.
* Wabernde Klänge *
Hallo, wie geht's?
- Gut. Und dir?
Hattest du einen guten Morgen?
- Ja.
Echt? Gut.
Ich hatte nur 2 Std. Schule.
- Nur 2 Std.? Warum?
Ich habe nur 2 Std. am Morgen.
Hast du diese Woche Prüfungen?
- Morgen.
Morgen? Was?
- Eine Geschichtsprüfung.
Aha, mit der Kolonialisierung,
nicht?- Ja.
Am Mittwoch?
- Ja.
Okay. Ist gut, bist du dabei?
- Ja, ja.
Ich schätze das extrem,
denn ich finde es einfach cool
mit ihm zusammen.
Ich habe nun mit Papi auch eine
noch engere Beziehung aufgebaut,
weil er mich in dieser schwierigen
Zeit immer begleitet hat.
Wenn ich mich nicht getraut habe,
auf den Zug zu gehen,
oder überhaupt rauszugehen,
konnte ich ihn immer anrufen.
Es ist auch immer gegangen.
Mein Job hat es mir erlaubt,
auch in den schwierigsten Zeiten
für Gioia da zu sein.
Mit Homeoffice konnte ich
vieles um sie herum planen.
Bis heute, wenn sie es benötigt.
Guten Appetit, Gioia!
- Dir auch!
Ich habe grosse Ängste ausgestanden.
Ich wusste nicht,
was mit ihr geschieht.
Sie war damals etwa 17.
Es gab eine grosse Hilflosigkeit,
weil man wohl da war für sie,
mit ihr reden und wahrnehmen konnte,
was sie erzählt.
Aber ihr zu helfen,
aus diesen Gefühlen,
dieser dunklen Phase herauszukommen,
hat Angst gemacht.
Auch Angst,
sie könne sich etwas antun
oder nicht mehr
aus diesem Tunnel rauskommen.
Das hat mich sehr ohnmächtig
und verzweifelt gemacht.
Ich hatte Angst
vor den Zwangsgedanken,
ich könnte mir etwas antun,
ich könnte noch tiefer fallen
und nicht mehr rauskommen
und es könnte noch schlimmer werden,
als es schon ist.
Einfach eine grosse Hilflosigkeit.
Ich wusste nicht,
was mit mir passiert.
Dann haben wir versucht, über
unsere Kontakte Therapien zu finden.
Und da haben wir erlebt,
wie man damit anstehen kann.
Es war Frühsommer
und es hatte keine Plätze.
Vom Frühsommer bis im Herbst,
um ein Erstgespräch zu bekommen.
Nicht um einen Platz zu bekommen,
sondern abzuwägen,
ob sie einen Platz bekommt
in einer Tagesklinik.
Heute, nach einem Jahr Auszeit, ist
Gioia zurück in Schule und Alltag.
* Mehrfaches Piepsen *
Was ich merke, ist: Eine gewisse
Verletzlichkeit ist geblieben.
Es ist wie eine Wunde, die man hat.
Die Sensibilität bleibt.
Das merkt man immer noch.
Deshalb der Wunsch,
dass das noch besser heilt
und nur die Erinnerung bleibt.
Aber insgesamt
ist es wirklich besser.
Siehst du das auch so?
- Ja. Es ist ein Heilungsprozess.
Ich habe Methoden gefunden,
um mit Dingen umzugehen,
die mir nicht guttun.
Solche Dinge
aus meinem Leben auszuschliessen,
sei es im Freundeskreis,
sei das bei den sozialen Medien,
was auch immer.
Wirklich aktiv dagegen vorgehen,
damit es mir
danach nicht schlecht geht.
Aber auch zu merken:
Heute ist kein guter Tag.
Aber nach einem weniger guten Tag
kommt wieder ein anderer Tag.
* Sanfte Gitarrenmusik *
Wenn ich vier Jahre zurückschaue
und jetzt ...
Es ist um einiges weniger
angespannt, emotional ruhiger.
Ähm ... ja.
Oder was meinst du?
- Ruhiger.
Ich habe gemerkt: Wenn ich mir
keine Sorgen mehr machen kann,
in mich und dich vertraue,
werde ich ruhiger und meine Sorgen
beunruhigen dich nicht mehr.
Das Einzige, wo ich mir immer noch
ab und zu sorgen mache, ist,
wenn er mit dem Töff unterwegs ist.
Aber nicht,
weil er nicht gut fahren würde.
Ich weiss, wie gut er fährt,
sondern es gibt einfach Idioten.
Das ist die Hauptsorge,
die ich ab und zu noch habe.
Das kommt von aussen.
Aber bez. Vertrauen oder dass er
sich schaden würde, so wie früher,
diese Sorge habe ich nicht mehr.
Das ist aber schön.
Gut zu hören, auf jeden Fall.
Wenn man einen Zeitsprung macht
und zurückschaut, muss ich sagen:
Boah, ich habe so viel mehr
Lebensqualität dazugewonnen.
Ich habe es gar nicht gemerkt,
es war ein schleichender Prozess.
Aber die Differenz ist schon da,
und zwar richtig fest.
* Sanfte Gitarrenmusik *
Ich habe immer noch
ein Problem damit,
mir selbst einzugestehen:
"Das habe ich gut gemacht."
"Keine Diskussion, das war megagut."
V.a. in der Schule bin ich sehr gut.
Aber ich habe immer noch
Selbstzweifel,
wenn es nicht die beste Note ist.
Aber durch Rückmeldungen der Lehrer
habe ich die Wahl nicht mehr,
mir einzureden,
ich würde es nicht gut machen.
Und ich denke,
im Betrieb mache ich es auch gut,
sonst wäre ich jetzt nicht
ins dritte Lehrjahr gekommen.
* Der Motor startet. *
Das Töfffahren gibt mir
Freiheit und Unabhängigkeit -
ein grosses Stück weit.
Als Persönlichkeit
fühle ich mich gefestigter.
Ich konnte das Vertrauen aufbauen,
zu wissen,
wer ich ungefähr bin,
was ich möchte,
was mir wichtig ist
und was meine Werte sind.
Ich habe keinen genauen Plan,
wie ich weitergehe im Leben,
aber ich habe so etwas
wie einen Kompass.
Ich weiss ungefähr,
in welche Richtung.
Wie Emil mussten auch Beneon
und seine Schulkollegin Lily lernen,
Vertrauen in sich und ihren Körper
zu gewinnen.
In der Ausbildung
gibt es viele Leute,
die eine gesunde Beziehung
zu ihrem Körper haben.
Es ist nur schwierig,
das Mass zu finden.
Auch mit dem,
was man täglich vermittelt bekommt.
Wir kriegen oft gesagt,
dass man so auszusehen hat
oder sich so zu bewegen hat.
Man muss da trotzdem noch
bei sich bleiben.
Schmeckt's?
- So macht Kochen Spass.
Früher hatte ich ziemliche Probleme
mit Essen.
Damit, was ich esse,
wie viel ich esse,
ob ich überhaupt esse.
Das kam vom Tanzen.
Ich habe Latein- und Standard-
wettkämpfe gemacht mit 13, 14.
Ich hatte eine feste Tanzpartnerin
und wir waren wirklich gut
und hatten schnell Erfolge
auf den Kinder- und Jugendturnieren.
Wir waren ganz oft
auf dem zweiten Platz.
Wir haben uns irgendwann gefragt,
weshalb wir nie
auf den ersten Platz gekommen sind.
Mein Lehrer hat das damit begründet,
dass wir zwei Puddings seien.
Dieses Wort
ist mir immer im Kopf geblieben.
Er hat gesagt, wir schwabbeln.
Da habe ich aufgehört zu essen.
So fing alles an.
Hey, voll gut!
Es gab Fälle, wo ich im Ballett-
unterricht Sprünge gemacht habe
und eine Lehrerin
mich angeschrien hat:
"Schwabbel, schwabbel, schwabbel!"
Ich begann zu weinen im Unterricht.
Im Nachhinein kann ich es verstehen.
Sie meinte nur, ich solle
meine Beininnenmuskulatur anspannen.
Aber für mich war das damals
der grösste Auslöser.
Ich habe stundenlang geweint,
ging nicht mehr zum Unterricht.
Ich traute mich nicht mehr rein.
Immer, wenn ich die Frau
gesehen habe, hatte ich Panik.
Es hat mir die Liebe zum Tanz
genommen für ein paar Monate.
Das war schlimm.
Mit der Zeit und mit der
Unterstützung von meinen Freunden
konnte ich es verstehen,
was sie gemeint hat.
Wenn ich eines Morgens merke,
ich will nicht aufstehen,
fühle mich depressiv,
will einfach versinken,
dann tu ich das nicht,
sondern stehe auf.
Oder ich lasse es kurz zu,
aber komme am selben Tag
wieder aus dem Loch raus.
Weil ich weiss, dass es am nächsten
Tag noch schwerer wird, aufzustehen.
Und wenn ich merke, ich habe
ein Problem mit meinem Körper,
dann esse ich sofort Fast Food.
Irgendwas Geiles
und dann geht es mir gut.
Dann gehe ich zu KFC
und hole mir Chicken.
Dann geht es mir blendend.
Wirklich: das Problem killen,
bevor es entstehen kann.
Ja?
Ist okay.
Kürzlich hat Beneon einen zweiten
Berufszweig für sich entdeckt.
Meine Konfektionsgrösse,
mein Brustumfang.
Stört der Pulli?
Schau, auf einer Seite sind Inches.
Ja, gut so.
Danke schön.
* Sie lachen. *
Ich habe Modeln nie gewagt,
weil ich dachte,
ich sei nicht schön genug dafür.
Im Sommer musste ich
Headshots machen für meinen Job,
da habe ich das Modeling entdeckt.
Es hat mir so viel Spass gemacht
vor der Kamera.
Das ist ein neuer Berufszweig,
den ich eingehen will.
Ich habe mich so gefreut,
dass ich aufgenommen wurde
und es jetzt auch umsetzen kann.
Die sind alle voll schön.
- Ja?
Ja, ich mag alle gerne.
- Danke schön!
Ich brauche eines mit Gesicht,
ein Halbkörper-
und ein Ganzkörperbild.
Hast du ein Ganzköperfoto?
- Irgendwie nicht, nein.
Aber da ist ja genug Körper drauf.
Ich mag meinen Körper, wie er ist.
Ich mag mich, wie ich bin.
Und merke auch, dass es gut ankommt.
Aber ich arbeite auch viel dafür,
dass ich das gesunde Verhältnis
behalten kann.
# Super bubble gum.
Super duper bubble gum.
# Super duper double bubble,
super duper double bubble,
# super duper double bubble gum.
# Super bubble gum.
Super duper bubble gum.
# Super duper double bubble,
super duper double bubble,
# super duper double bubble gum.
Seine Grenzen zu akzeptieren,
sich nicht zu überfordern,
bleibt nicht einfach.
Beim Training
hat sich Beneon am Knie verletzt.
Deshalb muss er beim Weihnachtsspiel
auf der Bühne
auf einige Einsätze verzichten.
* Fetziger Popsong:
"Happy" von Pharrell Williams *
# No offense to you,
don't waste your time.
# Here's why: Because I'm happy.
# Clap along if you feel
like a room without a roof.
# Because I'm happy ...
# Uh, uh, uh, uh.
* Melodiöser Gesang ohne Worte *
* Virtuose Rockmusik *
* Die Musik verklingt. *
Aljoscha?
Ich habe zum ersten Mal
seit einer Woche wieder gespielt.
Es war so schön, mit meinen Freunden
wieder auf der Bühne zu stehen.
Ich hätte weinen können
vor Schönheit,
weil es so Spass gemacht hat.
Es hat gar nicht geschmerzt,
dass ich so "wenig" gemacht habe.
Ich habe es trotzdem
einfach geliebt.
Die Bühne ist dein Ort.
Mittelpunkt ist immer mein Ort!
* Sanfte Musik *
Was ist das für ein Tag für dich,
Emil?
Aufregend.
Ich hatte den ganzen Tag
Berufsschule,
war nicht mehr in der Wohnung
seit der Besichtigung.
Leonie ist schon da.
Ich freue mich, dass ich wieder mal
in die Wohnung gehen kann.
Ich bin gespannt,
ob es immer noch so magisch aussieht
wie bei der Besichtigung.
* Sanfte, tänzelnde Musik *
* Beide lachen. *
... Wohnungseinrichtung aus?
Oh, drei Schlüssel? Vier?
Fünf! Einen hat deine Mutter schon.
Der Toaster ist im Schrank.
- Im Schrank?
Wir können nicht alles
in den Schränken verstauen.
Wir haben so viele Schränke.
Was soll da alles rein?
Das Einzige im Kühlschrank
ist Prosecco.
Schon geöffnet?
- Ja.
Wow. Schön, dass ich die Aussicht
nicht vermissen muss.
Es wäre schon schöner im Sommer.
- Ja. Aber so auch.
Wie schaust du in die Zukunft, Emil?
Hoffentlich optimistisch. Aber ...
Alle Anzeichen sind da,
dass es gut werden kann.
Ich vertraue darauf.
Bei dieser Aussicht.
- Bei dieser Aussicht!
Zum Wohl.
Kennst du mich noch?
Komm! Hoi!
Ja! Ja!
Ich bin nun an einem anderen Punkt.
Ich bin eine starke Frau
und schaffe es auch.
Aber ich muss es auch
immer wieder realisieren,
mir sagen, wo ich jetzt bin
im Gegensatz zu damals.
Vorher hatte ich eher Angst
vor der Zukunft.
Jetzt ist es viel optimistischer.
Ich kann mich
auf positive Dinge fokussieren.
Ich habe nie mehr so Angst
vor der Zukunft wie damals,
sondern sehe das Positive,
das sie bringen kann
und was sie Neues bringen kann.
Und deshalb eigentlich
sehr optimistisch.
* Sanfte Musik *
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
Madeleine Gassner - 2023